the gliac den is a hollow space right
below the enigmatic tie flow ruins which
is quite fitting these ruins are
dominated by dragon statues and gliox
are multi-headed dragons based on the
Hydra a creature from Greek mythology
who guards the underworld we can even
find a dragon statue with three heads
suggesting that those who construct a
Tai flow may have paid tribute to these
fearsome creatures but what's the
purpose of the gliac then the word Den
suggests the lair of a wild creature
which definitely fits but it also has
man-made features like statues of the
four hyrulean sages and a big Central
platform which hints that it could have
been an ancient battle arena of sorts
similar to the coliseums a place where
Warriors would challenge these powerful
creatures as a test of skill there's
even remnants of a small building these
Fighters could have retreated to or
prepared for battle lastly the den is
accessible from the outside despite the
fact that Tai flow is completely
surrounded by water normally areas like
this are only accessible if there's a
Chasm within said area on the surface
and man-made Bridges don't affect this
maybe this wall opened up during the
upheaval and would explain why gliox are
now free to terrorize Hyrule